that is a city in Switzerland yeah Davos
is not a conference it's a city gotcha
Davos Switzerland and World economic
Forum they get together the to them uh
Klaus Schwab is the founder of world
economic Forum I want to say started it
in the 70s by the way yeah and he's been
at it for a while it had a complete
different name at first it was Carl the
European something something Union can
you uh World economic Forum uh if you go
uh yeah European management forum is
what it was in 1971 this guy started it
just so you know he started eight years
seven years before you and I were born
six years before you and I were born so
he's been at it for a long time and
somehow someway he has now got the
control and the ears of people like
Justin Trudeau people like Joe Biden
presidents Prime Ministers around the
world that are following his lead okay
his lead and the fact that like World
economic I know it's economic but how
this sounds like a movie just watch 10
seconds of this just to kind of see how
this is my perspective this is
motivational speaking on steroids listen
to what he says okay dear friends
scientifically this is not a climate
crisis we are now facing something
deeper mass extinction air pollution
undermining ecosystem functions mass
extinction really putting Humanity's
future at risk this is a planetary
crisis
pause it okay so this is staring the
out of people number one that's
their goal it's a great way to get your
attention 100 we're all gonna die did
you ever go to church did you ever go to
church as a kid where the pastor you
know would baptize in a following way if
you don't give your life to Christ you
will go to hell let me tell you what
hell looks like in hell yeah you'll be
burning yes your skin the Imagine
temperature finally you're like holy
sauna's hot I don't want to go this
is coming and you're like you know what
I'm gonna put that water go ahead
whatever it is I'm willing to get
baptized in every possible way so it is
a very effective tactic to get the world
moving but they unify together and they
talk about you know Al Gore said we
should spend more money talking about
climate change and we stop we should
start defunding money that opposes
anything with climate change and some of
the stuff they're talking about you're
just like well you know I think I think
it's theatrics and I think that you know
first of all the I had Peter Zion have
you had him on this podcast I had him on
my podcast everybody's talking dude I
had him on my podcast I read his book
and you know he's a global strategist
who he would be hired for years like so
if you wanted to grow soybeans if you
had a company that Drew soybeans you
wanted to know he he knows the moisture
the rainfall in Brazil he knows
everything about everything when it
comes to the and the minutia and he was
breaking down the fact that if you think
we're off fossil fuels if you think that
any of these countries are going to go
it with just solar or uh Hydro or
whatever it is that's adorable that's
actually adorable it's adorable you
think our agricultural session you think
you're going to grow food without you
need irrigation guess what you need a
gasoline to to pump those fields you
need for herbicides and pesticides those
those are made with natural gas same
with fertilizer I mean there are the
fossil fuel print is crazy I I drive
around on a Tesla okay my my when I
bought that car when I bought it the
lithium battery is made on a cold Grid
in China when I bought it before I got
into it I had already polluted it was
like driving an F-150 50 000 55 000
miles yet in California I get to be in
the high occupancy Lane because I'm not
polluting the environment yeah it's a
joke that's so funny until we come up
with what's going to get us out of this
is not not regulation top down
regulation from the philosopher Kings
what's going to get us out of this is
innovation in Material Sciences and
things like that let me ask you guys a
question uh this really mostly for you
two only because you just found out
about what Davos was about seven minutes
ago so I use these I use my hands so the
whole concept is that it's a it's these
uh it's public private Partnerships
right so you have governments and what
was it you know
thousands of heads of states or hundreds
of countries heads of sharing ideas like
yeah how do you respond to a pandemic
that's Global things like that well yeah
correct meaning like so you also have
these private companies that I mean I I
tend to trust those companies more than
governments right I mean private
companies corporations care about the
bottom line shareholders so I tend to be
like all right you guys kind of got
something on
um how do you think we've got to the
point where we're only recognizing some
of the negativity surrounding it like
the theatrics it's fun but meaning like
they like you don't have an organ and
I'm not I don't defend the world not
gonna perform this is just those people
are can I get to the government let me
ask you the question how do we get to
the point where we're not even
highlighting any of the good and do we
even know any of the good that the world
economic Forum has done you don't do
this for 50 years and do no good I'm
more just wondering like what have they
done you look at this list of people who
are here this is the who's who's
you don't you don't know them so it's a
party you're not invited to okay party
you don't you're not invited to and they
all get there in their private jets and
they're all powerful people yeah the
idea is how could they ever be up to
something good but it's the same problem
I I have such a problem with when they
demonize somebody like Elon Musk who's a
risk-taking entrepreneur and and there's
this whole thing about if you're if
you're if you're an entrepreneur if you
made a lot of money chances are you took
huge risks chances are you worked I
don't know 18 hours a day for 30 years
chances are you just thought outside the
box and people don't that just reminds
other people of the things they're not
doing yeah and we all have some of that
in so I think sometimes there's a lot of
that although I think a healthy distrust
of powerful people when they get
together and start planning our lives
that's a good thing you know I'm not a
conspiracy theorist but I do think it's
kind of a good thing to kind of worry
about it what are you guys doing there
and why are you making rules that I have
like what about my voice you know that
kind of stuff that's why I think the the
point you made at the onset of the
podcast was so powerful is that you have
these elites on the coast that's just in
America yeah now extrapolate that to the
world yeah the elites of the world
making decisions for the farmer or the
mechanic or the comedian using his hands
like yeah that I think is ultimately
your point is that why it's like such
negative disdain at these people but if
you look at the list it's like I'd like
to know the names of the people that are
there to hold them accountable like this
I don't the cloud shop seems like the
like if you if Austin Powers was written
in real life and they're like who do you
want to play Dr Evil it's like yeah
I'm a German people maybe yeah I want to
make everybody a machine yes yes
so him is a he talked about this Pat
like what a horrible like yeah face for
a company but if you look at these
people that are there these are actually
the people movers and Checkers you would
hope trying to help the world it's just
I think they do I think I don't think
they're out to destroy the world I think
everybody wants to create the world in
their own image I mean I'm sorry but the
the Iraq War was that you had a group of
people who most had never been to the
Middle East certainly didn't speak
Arabic didn't know much about the didn't
know even the difference between a Sunni
and Ashia yeah and had the hubris to
think they could restructure the Middle
East right Babylon Iraq been around 5
000 years that's a large historical
footprint but we're going to come along
and restructure your country and it
didn't go that well no but that's
what is the list by the way can we see
the name you keep hiding the names at
the top I I I'm thinking like Robinson
well these are Tony John Kerry Tony
Blair keep going up let's see horses
achieve uh secret intelligence
[Laughter]
Rob you're going the other way I mean
you're looking at London I saw Joe
manchin Kristen Cinema these are U.S
senators
governor of Georgia Beyonce okay
Beyonce's in Dubai that's the whole keep
going up keep going up keep going up
keep going up keep going up let's see
who's pritzker the governor of uh
Illinois right minister of uh State
Finance Affairs then you see a lot of
ahmeds in Muhammad
Abdullah oh yeah that's serious yeah a
lot of them there's some money up there
yeah
one guy gives is given a speech and he
says
um
he says look am I going to be the only
one person that's going to talk about uh
we're going to get together World
economic forum and we're going to talk
about climate change but nobody wants to
talk about billionaires not paying taxes
it's not like is that what are we going
to do that are we all going to come at a
meeting like this and no one wants to
pay their fair share of taxes oh great
he said that at the world economic
foreign
[Laughter]
no you haven't seen it anyways he says
this is that at the world economics
what are you what's your what are your
thoughts honestly look here's I mean
first of all there are no Assyrian names
there so that's a huge problem yeah the
representation for you look no Patrick
we have more ethereum representation
here than anywhere in the world
me and him that's crazy I know that's
true insane dude go to the top of the
list by the way if you don't mind I'll
tell you this my my idea with the with a
meeting like this look at that they have
yeah I mean listen here's all you got to
know pretty much every country the most
powerful people are there uh Elon Musk
is like I'm not going to a boring
meeting like this and they said oh we
haven't invited him since 2015 they
bragged about it okay so Elon Musk is he
hasn't been a double since uh boring his
organization is going to keep going down
they said yeah they're having a vitamins
since 2015. so listen you know they're
defending themselves as well that uh we
don't really want Elon here so if you
don't want Elon there and he's the guy
worldwide doesn't give you a lot lot of
credibility if you're trying to save the
world he's an operator doing it I don't
have a problem with a meeting like this
if there is what debate debate yeah
there is none if you get together and
the panel all agree what the hell are
you getting together for well that's a
huge that's a great point because I I
would say with all these different
people human beings don't agree
right here in this room if we had if I
brought up one subject but greatest
basketball player in the world we'd all
have to figure it out yeah so so at the
end of the day people don't agree and
you know you have to worry about you
know one of the things that you know
James Madison when he wrote The
Federalist Papers was all about faction
how do we guard against faction because
you have balance of powers and you break
up you you have checks and balances in
government but it takes one charismatic
leader to get a lot of power and
influence and then and then absorb
another faction and then absorb that
faction pretty soon one guy's
controlling everything that was the
biggest challenge facing that's why
James Madison is a genius and he figured
out a way to avoid that so but I think
in this case you've got people that
don't speak the same language they're
from different countries different
cultures they don't like each other they
have competing interests so the idea
that they're all getting together like
there's this Illuminati you know my
buddy made a lot of money and he he's a
in the banking world and you know and he
he wanted to get this huge fund together
it's so funny and he needed he wanted to
get these six billionaires together
that's all I want to do just in a room
so we can he wanted to create this fun
he had this amazing idea he's made crazy
money he owns you know Banks so he wants
to get these guys he runs in these
circles and because I was talking about
conspiracy he calls me and he goes hey
dude let me explain something to you
okay I tried to get six billionaires
together and I couldn't get them in the
same room because they all hate because
one guy had banged this guy's wife oh
God the other guy had screwed him in a
deal they all hated each other they all
wanted to kill each other so they
weren't going to work together and
that's that probably way more typical
thank God then it's not yeah and now
there were Secret pacts in Europe I mean
before we had democracies and stuff a
war would start you wouldn't even know
what was doing because the austral
Hungarian Empire is talking to you know
this group over here and you know they
would create these secret alliances but
I think that that's harder to pull off
now yeah I hope so if you like this clip
and you want to watch another one click
right here and if you want to watch the
entire podcast click right here
[Music]